huge
news Sean we can report um based on
senior military sources that us war
planes have carried out air strikes
tonight inside Syria against Iranian
proxy forces we don't know the number of
strikes uh we were told earlier today
that to expect that perhaps uh f-15s and
f-16s would be involved in the air
strikes but we don't have confirmation
yet how about how many war planes but
those strikes have been carried out I'm
told uh it is in response to the more
than dozen strikes against us bases uh
the message is a clear message designed
uh to Iran and its proxy forces to stop
carrying out these uh drone and Rocket
attacks against us bases um but I'm told
that the planes have safely left the
area and that the air strikes uh are
complete at this time um they were a
targeting multiple locations inside
Syria and Iran Iranian proxy forces Sean
so so important Jennifer thank you for
that breaking news especially in light
of the fact that American forces have
been attacked by both Iraq and by Syria
uh we appreciate that news